Having covered how machines communicate across a local area
network, we now turn our attention to how they communicate
across the internet and the network layer of our
hierarchy. Whereas other layers use a variety of technologies and
protocols, the network layer really only uses IP, which
is short for internet protocol. Every machine on the internet
proper gets a unique 32 bit address. Which is usually
written out as four decimal numbers between 0 and 255.
So, for example, 72.14.248.239 is currently the
IP address for Udacity's home page. Ranges of
addresses are allocated by regional internet registries. All
of which, are under control by IANA, the
International Assign Numbers Authority. The range of themselves
are commonly specified by a 32 bit IP
followed by a slash, and then the number
of bits understood to specify the network ID.
This is referred to as CIDR notation. The first, number of bits of
the 32, specify the range and then the rightmost bits specify
the particular host. For example, MIT was allocated long ago the
range, 18.0.0.0 slash 8. Meaning
that any IP starting with 18 belongs to MIT. There are
about 2 to the 24th of them.
Georgia Tech has the range 130.207.0.0/16 meaning that
any IP starting with 130.207 belongs to Georgia Tech. There are about 2 to the
16th of those because there are 16 unspecified bits in this range. At the time
of this recording a New Jersey company called
Linode has been allocated the address range 50.116.48.0/20.
So this gives them 12 bits of host, and the range 50.116.48.0
to 50.116.63.255. Again about two to
the 12th IPs. IPs have become a precious commodity these days, as most all
of them have been allocated. And not very
efficiently. For instance, tech savvy as they are,
MIT is probably not using all 2 to the 24th, or 16 million of it's addresses.
One solution to this problem is simply to
expanded the address space to use more bits. The
new internet protocol, called IPv6, the old one
is call IPv4, uses 128 bit addresses. The problem
is that IPV4 is so universal, and so
many other systems depend on it, that adoption of
the new protocol has been slow. And I encourage
you to read more about this on your own.